the FBI and Homeland Security Department
issued a new warning to American energy
companies about potential cyber attacks
on nuclear facilities the warning says
hackers working for a foreign government
have been able to find vulnerabilities
and companies that operate nuclear
plants Russian cyber criminals are
suspected jephthah gays is in Washington
with the new reasons for concern Jeff
good morning good morning their
frequency and intensity of these cyber
attacks have escalated recently and
that's what really prompted federal
officials to issue the warning late last
month among the companies targeted by
hackers is a Wolf Creek nuclear
operating corporation that's in Kansas
US officials say the hackers were able
to penetrate the business side of the
nuclear facility but officials insist
that there was no threat to public
safety or to operations at the plant
last month the FBI and Department of
Homeland Security issued a joint report
warning businesses to watch out for
specific types of cyber attack attempts
by hackers there was a similar report on
Russian malicious cyber activity in
December in the latest incidents
officially we're told that it is too
early to attribute the attacks to a
specific country however former
officials familiar with Russian cyber
capabilities say they have to be at or
close to the top of the list of
potential suspects Jeff Jeff the case
thank you very much